Hello, everyone.
Once again, this is
Dr. Gindi with the
second half of the
temperature-related
lectures. This one
is going to be
about heat-related
injuries and how you
take care of them.
The objectives
will be that we
are going to try
to figure out
how the body
gets rid of heat.
There are lots of
different mechanisms,
but Dr. Savinova
gives a lecture on
this entitled
thermoregulation, which she
does a much better
job than I will be
doing, and I'm just
going to be touching
on them insofar as
they impact upon
how we cool people
down who are too hot.
We're going to
also talk about
this phenomenon
called acclimation,
whereby people who
live in hot climates
do a better job
at cooling off.
They kind of get
used to it, and there
are some physiological
reasons for that.
We're going to
be talking about
the way we
distinguish different
levels of heat
-related illness,
And then for each level,
we're going to talk
about the appropriate
therapy. And lastly,
we're going to talk
about how difficult it
is to take care of these
people because some
of the therapy itself
causes complications.
All right, let's
get into it.
It's a great movie.
This is Al Pacino
in The Devil's
Advocate. I
thought it was an
appropriate
photograph to show.
Great movie if you
get a chance to see
it. Okay, the
epidemiology, of course,
is that the heat
-related illnesses that
we see in the emergency
department vary
with weather.
Obviously, they happen
a lot more in the
hot weather, and that
is referenced with
the Journal of Duh.
And we also see it
less in people who
are used to living
in warmer climates,
and they are
physiologically adapted, and
we're going to talk
about how they do
that. And there's
also some cultural
adaptation in areas
where it's always hot.
People have air
conditioning all the time
in every place. And
in places that don't
experience it that
often, the reason for
a lot of the morbidity
and mortality is
because they don't
have air conditioning.
And in 2003, there
were 688 heat-related
deaths. Now, that's
not a lot in 2003,
but in the heat
wave of 2010, which
was an incredible
heat wave in Europe,
just in France
alone, there
were almost
15,000 deaths.
That's because
they don't really
have air conditioning
in France, and
they got really
caught by surprise.
And how do we get rid
of heat? Well, all
different mechanisms,
and as I said,
Dr. Savanova's going
to cover this a
little bit more than
I am. Radiation is
where you transfer
heat by electromagnetic
waves from an object
like a person to
the environment or
a colder object, but
it goes through
electromagnetic waves.
Evaporation is mostly
how we lose heat
by sweating, but
also some of the
evaporation happens just
from our respiration.
When we exhale, it's
humidified by our
lungs, and we do
lose water that way.
and that's going
to be a main way
that we're going
to be caring for
people by taking
advantage of
evaporation as the
mainstay of therapy.
Convection is where
you get heat transfer
by something moving over
an object that's hot
and it could be either
air or liquid and
you get these currents
just pulling the heat
away and conduction
is direct contact
between two surfaces
and that's what happens
when you put an ice pack
on someone who's hot
they the heat just goes
from the hot person
into the cold pack
and we use lots of
different methods but
evaporation is the main
one so how do we respond
to being hot well
we do vasodilate
because we're trying to
get rid of the heat
and so by sending blood
to the periphery of
our body like the skin
we're able to dissipate
heat and And because
we do that, then that
volume goes away from
the core part of our
body because it's
going to the periphery.
And therefore, the
****** volume decreases
when we're vasodilated.
And so as a response
to that, because we
have no preload, so
if you don't have any
blood going to the
heart because most of
it's hanging around
in the periphery, then
****** volume goes
down. And so in order to
keep up with heart
rate, you remember that
all-famous formula,
which is cardiac output
equals heart rate
times ****** volume. So
the heart rate goes up.
That's just a natural
response to a diminishing
****** volume.
People who are
old and people who
have dysrhythmias
and people who
have medicines that
don't allow them
to mount a
chronotropic response,
Maybe I didn't define the
term, but chronotropic
means speeding
up the heart, and
inotropic means making
the heart pump harder.
And so people who
are on medicines that
diminish the ability to
raise your heart rate,
like beta blockers,
for example, will
limit their tachycardic
response. So they
can't really increase
their cardiac output
when their preload is
diminished. And so they
have some trouble.
And people with
dysrhythmias may not,
also for other various
reasons, not get the
preload that they need.
And this can result in
myocardial ischemia,
especially people
who have already
limited flow in their
coronary arteries
because they have lesions
blocking the flow.
And that can make
things even worse.
And this can lead to
dysrhythmias in and of
itself because you're
ischemic from not
feeding the conduction
system of your heart.
And finally,
the lack of blood
flow to the really
important organs caused
them to decompensate.
How do we figure
out how much water
people lose? Well, we
start to sweat when
it's about 37 degrees
Celsius. Sorry, we
don't say centigrade,
we say Celsius.
And the elderly
people, though, they
don't start to
sweat until they get
even a little bit
hotter. And so that's
why they can't
get rid of some of
the heat as well as
a younger person.
Just a little note
is that for every
pound of water
weight that we lose,
you lose 450
milliliters of fluid.
And so if you want to
replace it, then you
give about half a liter.
That's close enough.
The people who know
what their normal dry
weight is, meaning not
fluid overload, are
the people in renal
failure. because they get
dialyzed three times
a week usually and
they're dialyzed down to
their dry weight. That
is what the goal is
with each session of
dialysis because your
kidneys are not making
any urine so your
fluid builds up in your
body and so you're wet
before you start your
dialysis and when you
get dialyzed you want
to meet that goal to
go back to what we call
dry weight. Most
people don't know their
dry weight, so you have
to kind of estimate.
There are other
medicines that
can interfere
with heat removal.
Anticholinergic agents,
remember blind as a
bat, hot as a hair,
dry as a bone, red as
a beet. That's the acronym
for the anticholinergic
toxidrome, which
you'll learn about
next year when I do
my tox lectures, but
they impair sweating.
That's what the dry as
a bone is. And so if
you can't sweat, you
can't get rid of heat,
which is the main
mechanism for getting
rid of heat is sweating.
If you're on a
diuretic, you're going
to be volume depleted.
That's kind of
the idea of
diuretics. So that if
you're in congestive
heart failure, you
can't handle a lot
of volume because
your heart just
can't pump it around.
Then diuretics help
you deal with less
of a volume so
that you're always
operating with a little
bit of dehydration.
And because
you're slightly
dehydrated, that's
going to decrease your
cardiac output for
the same reason,
preload deficit.
Phenothiazines, those
are usually anti-nausea
medicines or anti
-psychotic medications.
And they have, nothing
is a pure medicine,
despite what people
want you to believe
who make drugs. And
these phenothiazines,
as well as having
dopaminergic activity,
anti-dopaminergic
activity, They also
have anticholinergic
properties, and so
they're going to cause
the same problems as
pure anticholinergic
agents themselves.
And because they
also affect dopamine,
they diminish
dopamine's effect on the
hypothalamus, and you
know that the hypothalamus
is the main
thermoregulatory center
of the body, and so
you're not going to
be able to get that
correct set point.
beta-blockers and
calcium-general blockers
we mentioned before
will not allow you to
have an appropriate
response to volume
depletion or shunting of
blood to the periphery
so you won't be able
to mount a tachycardic
response and
sympathomimetic agents like
******* or
methamphetamine they cause
cutaneous vasoconstriction
that's what
sympathomimetics do and
so you can't dissipate
the heat from your
periphery and they also
cause you to move around
a lot because you're
just you know on a
high demand and that
increases muscle
activity which increases
heat production and
they also don't allow
you to sweat because
if they cause cutaneous
vasoconstriction
ethanol is usually a co
-ingestion with almost
every toxidrome and
with a lot of people
who don't know enough
to remove themselves
from hot situation.
They don't do the
smart thing by going
into an air-conditioned
environment. But
also ethanol inhibits
your secretion
of ADH. And ADH is
what's going to cause
you to retain water.
So if you don't
have enough of it,
you're going to get
rid of water. And
that's going to make you
more dehydrated.
Alcohol makes you
dehydrated, but it
also makes you stupid.
Our Aldous Chapman
played for the Yankees,
and he doesn't play
for the Yankees
anymore, but he always
noticed that when the
rest of the players
were not sweating, he
was sweating. Of
course, throwing 105.8
miles an hour is going
to cause you to exert
yourself and cause
some heat production,
but he sweated even
when he was pitching
at a normal speed
because he grew up in
Cuba, and Cuba is a
hotter climate, and it
is harder for people
who are not from a
climate to start to
sweat. So people from
hotter climates start
to sweat at a lower
body temperature. And
they also sweat more.
They sweat about
three liters
per hour. That's a lot.
And they also increase
their aldosterone
level. Aldosterone
makes you hold on
to fluid, increases
your plasma volume,
and it does so by
conserving sodium.
And as a result, when
you sweat, you're
losing less salt. And I
spelled because wrong.
You're losing less
salt, but you're losing
more water. And water
evaporating is what's
causing you to
diminish your heat. So
you don't really want
to lose salt. You want
to just lose water.
And so aldosterone
allows you to do a more
efficient sweating.
It also causes a
dilatation, I'm sorry,
people who are
acclimatized dilate their
cutaneous vessels at
a lower temperature
and just get, they
radiate heat more and
have more convection
of heat at a lower
core temperature. So
they'll start to have
that happen when
they're less hot than
a normal person who's
not acclimatized,
acclimated.
Let's talk about the
heat illnesses from the
most mild to the most
severe. The milder
heat illnesses probably
have happened to a lot
of people, heat edema.
When you've been out
in the hot weather or
been walking a lot,
you get cutaneous
vasodilatation. As we
mentioned, it's one of
the mechanisms that you
have responsible for
getting rid of heat in
a hot environment that
when you vasodilate,
you also increase
aldosterone and that
vasodilatation and the
aldosterone lead to venous
pooling. So the veins
get bigger and they
also get more permeable.
And so the fluid
leaks out from the
vascular space into the
interstitial space. And
that's what makes you
swell. And it's usually
a gravity-dependent
thing, so your ankles
and your feet swell.
And the treatment
is basically just
elevation and it
usually goes away.
Prickly heat is a
very, very common rash
that you see when
people are wearing more
constrictive clothing
and they're sweating
a lot and those
sweat glands can get
clogged either from
the clothes themselves
or perhaps they put
some ointment on,
a skin softener that
will block the sweat
glands from secreting
what they secrete.
And they get inflamed
and they look like
this very classic
picture, They're little
tiny macules that
are also popular, and
they're very kind of
discreet, and they're
of varying sizes, and
they don't coalesce.
That's a pretty classic
appearance of prickly
heat. We could also
call it miliaria
rubra. That's probably
the more billable
diagnosis, but we all
know it as a heat rash.
Basically, take the
clothing that's occluding
the flow of sweat
off, put the person
with some light, clean,
loose-fitting clothing,
and people who live
in extremely hot
climates, such as in
the Arabian Peninsula or
the subcontinent of
India, usually know
this. And they wear
already beforehand loose
-fitting light clothing
that allows for
ventilation and no direct
skin exposure to the
sun. You can also
try calamine lotion,
antihistamines to
make the itching less,
clorhexidine and low
-potency steroids. You don't
want to put a lot
of steroids on your
body because you can
absorb steroids. and if
you put a lot on and
you are absorbing it,
you don't know how
much you're absorbing.
So if you need
to put a lot
of steroids on your body,
then maybe oral steroids
because you know
exactly what you're
getting when you
give oral steroids
or any kind of other
systemic steroids. So
be careful with topical
steroids if you're
using a lot of it.
Okay,
heat cramps.
These are painful involuntary
muscle contractions
that occur after
you exert yourself
in a hot environment.
They can actually occur
even when you're not
in a hot environment,
but they're either
entire muscles or muscle
groups that contract
on their own. And it's
very, very painful,
and it isn't really
understood how this
happens. Many people get
these frequently when
they overdo exercise,
but they also can
get it just from
light exercise
in extreme heat.
the causes are thought
to be due that the
muscle is fatigued perhaps
built up with lactic
acid and dehydration
also might play a part
in it as well as fluid
and electrolyte local
disturbances in the
muscle but really
nobody knows what causes
heat cramps the treatment
is cool to patient if
they are dehydrated
or electrolyte deficient
then replace those
and if you're let's
say your thigh muscle
cramps up. You want to
stretch the muscle more
than it is already
contracting and pull it
more, and that usually
resolves the cramp.
More aggressive
therapies are diazepam,
which is a muscle
relaxant. Probably doesn't
work, and magnesium
is also a muscle
relaxant. Decreases
your reflexes as well.
Probably doesn't
work as well,
but they have been tried.
Now we're getting a
little bit more serious.
Heat exhaustion
is where the body
temperature starts to
go up. So your body is
getting overwhelmed
by a hot ambient
environment, but your
mental status is normal.
And that is the
distinguishing factor
between that and the
more serious heat ******,
which we talk about
in a slide or two.
So you get water and
salt depleted and
you You can have a
myriad of symptoms
from headache,
nausea, vomiting,
melees, muscle cramps.
You can feel like
you're going to
lose consciousness.
You're sort of by
definition dehydrated.
And as a response,
you're appropriately
tachycardic. You have
orthostatic changes.
Now, I just wanted
to just maybe quickly
talk about how to
directly do orthostatic
vital signs, which
you will be called
upon in third year
very frequently to do
because they're a little
bit time-consuming,
and the nurses
usually don't do them.
and the attending
doesn't have time, so
they're going to ask
you to do it. The word
ortho, remember from
organic chemistry,
ortho, parametra.
Ortho means straight
across, so the word
ortho means straight.
Orthopedic means
straight child because
the history of orthopedic
surgery was, well,
orthopedists before
they were surgeons,
was they used to put
children with club
foot or scoliosis in
these contraptions,
and that's what they
did 300 years ago.
And it's only
more recently that
orthopedists have begun
to operate and fix
bones intraoperatively
with plates and
screws and all the
things that they do.
And so the word
ortho means straight.
So orthostatic changes
is kind of like
an oxymoron. What it
means is the thing
that should be same
straight, static,
straight, orthostatic,
is changing.
So we want to know if
it is changing. And
the way to do it is
straight, meaning lying
down, check the pulse
and the blood pressure,
and then have the
person stand, and then
you want to check the
pulse and the blood
pressure. The most
sensitive first thing that
you will notice when
someone is volume
depleted is they will
feel lightheaded. If they
say, oh, I'm feeling
it, Doc, when I'm
standing up, it's
positive. You don't need to
do anything more. But
if they don't feel
lightheaded, the first
thing to go is your
compensatory mechanism,
which is tachycardia.
And it is only when
you decompensate
that your blood
pressure drops,
okay? So don't
do orthostatic
changes in the
sitting position
because that's
not straight.
Now, if they can't
stand because they're
either having amputations
or they're just
too symptomatic, that's
fine. Then you can
do it just sitting.
And if they're positive
because they're feeling
lightheaded, that's
positive too. in the
sitting position,
but if they're not,
you need to stand them.
Okay, now, other things
that happen is you
get hemoconcentrated,
so you may not
accurately rely on your
hemoglobin concentration
or your hematocrit as
being accurate, and
that goes with any
type of dehydration,
that those numbers
will change, and maybe
they'll be a normal
hemoglobin, but when you
rehydrate them, they're
actually anemic.
Electrolyte findings
really depends on
whether they've tried to
replete their electrolytes
with something like
Gatorade or a salt
and sugar water oral
rehydration therapy.
They're usually
dehydrated when they have
heat exhaustion, but
they're able to still
sweat. That is
another thing that
distinguishes heat
exhaustion from heat ******.
Heat exhaustion
still sweats and is
trying to get rid of
the heat, and that's
why they're usually
dehydrated. So I
should probably get
rid of the butt in that
sentence. They're
usually dehydrated
and sweating
remains intact.
So you want to elevate
their legs because
you want as much as
possible to get the
remaining volume in their
body to the important
organs like the
heart and the brain.
And if they're outside,
get them to a cool
area and give them what
they need if they're
depleted. You can give
them ****** because
they have a normal
mental status. You don't
want to give oral
anything to anyone who has
a diminished mental
status because they may
aspirate it, and that'll
be driven home with
the next couple of
slides. It's possible
that they may feel
nauseated and not want to
drink. Then you can
definitely do an IV, and
sometimes that makes
you feel a lot better,
quicker.
But you can get
it down usually
with small
frequent sips of
electrolyte
replacement solution.
And you don't need to
start an IV necessarily.
And this is most often
treated outside the
hospital. For those
of you who've maybe
attended the New York
City Marathon as a
healthcare provider,
you'll see that this
is done all the time
without sending people
to the hospital in
the medical tents.
Now we'll get to
the serious one.
This is heat ******.
This is where
your body
temperatures are
elevated above 40
degrees centigrade,
Celsius, I'm sorry,
Celsius, and your mental
status is altered.
So that's really what
defines heat ****** and
what distinguishes it
from heat exhaustion.
We really don't
understand all the
mechanisms involved with heat
******, but you're
impairing your normal
thermoregulatory response.
It's overwhelmed.
And I guess that's
another way of saying
it's decompensating.
This is a life
-threatening emergency.
It can affect
lots of organs
and is definitely
something that needs
immediate attention.
And often, they're
not sweating. Now,
they can be sweating.
the real key
distinguishing factor
of heat ****** from heat
exhaustion is the
mental status changes.
But they're usually not
sweating, but
they can be.
Hypothermia, when
you're experiencing
heat ******, causes
direct cell toxicity.
Cells are meant to exist
in a certain temperature,
and the proteins
inside of them and the
proteins outside the
cells will denature. You
know, their quaternary
structure will not be
what they need to be
when they're warmer.
And that can lead
to cell death.
The membranes rupture
and you get these
toxins that should be
in the cell, outside
of the cell. And that
causes an inflammatory
response, which
leads to endovascular
damage, which you need
to have endothelial
cells so blood vessels
can function. And
that leads to multisystem
organ failure.
The kidneys, the
liver, the lungs, the
brain, the heart, all
of those things require
blood flow. And when
the endothelium of
the vascularity is
damaged, you're not
going to get the blood
flow that you need.
And also the
endothelial cells, not
only the endothelial
cells are damaged,
but the vascular
permeability is
affected. And so the
blood vessels leak
fluid into the
interstitial space.
And this also activates
the coagulation
cascade. Endothelial
damage and
vascular permeability
causes you to clot.
And when you clot
a lot, a bazillion
little clots everywhere
in your body, you're
going to use up your
clotting factors.
And when you do,
that can lead to DIC.
DIC is Disseminated
Intravascular Coagulation.
So you've used
up your clotting
factors and you have all
these clots everywhere,
but because you
have no clotting
factors, you're also
bleeding. And as you can
intuit, this is a
bear to treat. It is
very difficult to treat
DIC, and that is a
very common complication
of heat ******.
Classic heat ******
occurs during periods
of high ambient
temperature, obviously,
and usually the old
and the young who can't
really dissipate heat
like younger people
are the ones who are
most affected. The
elderly, because their
senescent compensatory
mechanisms just don't
work the way they
used to, all of the
things we mentioned
about how we dissipate
heat don't work as
well when you're old.
And the very young,
I talked about it in
my previous lecture,
have a high surface
area to volume
ratio. And so
they're going to get
hotter faster,
which is going to
make their core
get hotter faster.
And so when you're
first born, it's
especially problematic
when you're an infant,
if you're left in
a hot environment.
And it can happen
quickly, but it usually
takes a long time to
build up heat ******.
And of course,
they're volume
depleted and they
have electrolyte
disturbances almost
by definition.
People who have
problems with their
normal physiology
and also
psychology, they
don't really know
enough to come in
out of the heat.
and or they have
problems with mounting a
cardiovascular response
and or they're on
medications which can
inhibit that appropriate
cardiovascular response
are at a greater
risk to get classic
heat ******. Some of the
meds, anticholinergic,
diuretics, and
antipsychotics we
talked about. People
with Raynaud's
disease, they often
get vasoconstriction
inappropriately so
they can't get rid of
heat as well. And
also we talked about
sympathomimatics and
alcohol in previous slides.
So the classic
example, sometimes it's
on an exam, is an
elderly person who lives
alone with no air
conditioning and it's
a hot summer day.
Those are the ones
who suffer classically
from heat ******.
There's also a nuanced
version of it. it's
the same real thing,
but with the added
variable that you're
making more heat
by exerting yourself
too much. So it doesn't
have to happen on
a very hot day if
you're making too much
heat. And it usually
happens when you're
first doing your
athletic activity.
So you're not really
conditioned and you
can't lose the heat as
efficiently as if
you were conditioned.
And
the effects of exertional
heat injury can
be anywhere from the
mild heat edema all
the way to heat ******.
So be ready if you're
going to be manning
the marathon to deal
with all of the
spectrum of the disease.
This is a particular
type of heat related,
a particular cause of
heat related injury.
It's called confinement
hyperparexia.
Unfortunately,
and so sad, these
little babies get
left in a car.
Usually it's not
intentional and the
parent goes out
of the car just to
do something really
quickly and they
leave the baby in
the car because
for whatever reason
they don't want to take
the baby with them
and within 10 minutes
a hot car that's not
ventilated can get to
be 140 degrees fahrenheit
which is 60 degrees
celsius that is
really hot and they're
at risk because they
don't have those
regulatory mechanisms
that are developed yet
and that's what incate
means they can't move
themselves they can't
open the door and
they also as I mentioned
before have a higher
surface area to volume
ratio which gets
them hotter faster in
their core and another
type of confinement
hyperparexia a subcategory
is people who stow
away or trying to
cross the US Mexican
border I suppose it
happens to other borders
but this is the one
that's more famous in
the news. And in the
year 2000, we don't
know exactly how many,
but it's estimated
that 500 people died
in the back of those
trucks because of the
confinement
hyperparexia when
they're trying to
cross the border.
And it's very sad.
How does seed ******
affect the nervous
system? Well, the
brain is the canary
in the coal mine.
It will really try
to auto-regulate
the temperature of
itself as well as
its own blood supply.
And so when it's
really not getting what
it needs for whatever
reason, substrates,
blood flow, it's
going to be affected
first before other
parts of the body. And
so that's going to
be your warning sign.
I'm sorry, after other
parts of the body.
So that's going to
be your warning sign
that the rest of your
body is also at risk.
And for some reason,
the cerebellum, which
is responsible for
coordination, is the
most susceptible part
of your brain you can
get irritable and
confused you can do
crazy things hallucinate
and you can have
upgoing toes which is
abnormal and just another
little teaching
point that i like to
tell my dpr pods is that
when you're recording
things that aren't
a hundred percent
absolutely agreed upon
by every single person
who's potentially
reading your note that
you shouldn't say
positive or negative.
You should say what
happens. So if you
say positive Babinski,
I don't know that
you know that positive
means normal or
positive means abnormal.
So I don't know
if a first year medical
student knows that.
And I don't know
that you know that I
know that you know
that I know that you
that. So don't even
write positive or
negative, just write
toes up, toes down or
abnormal or normal.
That tells me that I
know what happened.
You can get decorticate
and decerebrate.
I always remember
decerebrate has a lot more
ease in it than
decorticate. So extension
is for ease. That's
decerebrate where you
extend your arms and
decorticate is the opposite
where you flex your
arms. Decerebrate
is worse because is your
entire cerebrum. And
decorticate is your
cortex, which is bad,
but not as bad as the
cerebrate. And you can
get all this kind of
posturing, which means
you're not getting
what your brain needs.
And you can even get
hemiplegia. So if you
have a pre-existing
lesion in your brain
or a pre-existing
area of your brain
that's in jeopardy, just
losing the amount of
blood supply and
substrate to that area
can make a subclinical
****** show up or
even cause a ******
because you're not
perfusing that part
of the brain more than
you're perfusing other
parts of the brain.
And of course,
coma where you
have a diminished
level of
consciousness is
a very bad sign.
Seizures are really,
really common. And this
is not good because
when you are convulsing,
then you're actually
making more heat and
that's the last thing
you need when you're
already hot so definitely
need to control
seizure activity when
people are really hot
organs that are
dysfunction well you're
hypotensive because you're
usually volume depleted
and you also are trying
to shunt your blood
to the periphery to
get rid of that heat
so you're losing fluid
it more in the core.
You want to give people
IV fluids if they're,
certainly if their
mental status is
diminished, you don't
want to put anything in
their mouth. That's
really, really important.
And if they don't get
better with IV fluids,
you can consider
inotropes. Remember,
inotropes make the heart
squeeze harder. And if
you're going to do it,
you want to use those
inotropes. They're
also categorized with
this broad term as
pressors, which is
kind of a misnomer
because presses implies
that it's pressing
the vascularity,
but that's more of an
alphanergic effect.
But people use that
word to describe all
kinds of inotropes as
well as chronotropes,
as well as systemic
constrictors.
So inotropes are ones
that will squeeze
the heart, which is
what you really want
to do. And you don't
want to constrict the
periphery because
you want to dissipate
heat. So alphraagenergic
agents like
norepinephrine and
dopamine, they constrict
the periphery. They
have alpha effects. So
you want to avoid
those. You want more
of a beta effect
that you get from the
dobutamine or low-dose
dopamine. So those
are the go-to inotropes
if you do need them
at all. Usually fluids
are good enough.
Electrolyte disturbances
happen almost
invariably. You can get
hyper or hypokalemic.
You can lyse your
blood cells, which is
where your potassium
lives. And when you
lyse, you get
hyperkalemic because more
potassium is in your
serum. And that can
lead to life-threatening
dysrhythmias.
And you can get
hypernatremic because
you're volume depleted
and you're trying
to hold on to as much
fluid as possible.
I'm sorry. You are
trying to get rid of as
much fluid as
possible so you get
hemoconcentrated and you
get sodium concentrated.
and because you're not
perfusing your organs
you uh the kidneys
are are some of those
organs are not being
perfused they might
start failing but they
also can fail if you
get muscle breakdown
so if you've been
exerting yourself and
you get rhabdomyolysis
and i told you the story
in the last lecture
about the woman who
had a 25 000 uh level
of cpk five days after
a split spin class
Well, she did okay. Her
kidneys did not shut
down. But that is one
of the most frightening
complications of
rhabdomyolysis, that
the breakdown products
of your muscle will end
up clogging your
kidney tubules. And you
have this classic-looking
tea-colored urine.
And you can appreciate
that the urine in
this container is not
just concentrated. It's
not just super yellow.
It's actually tea
-colored, which implies
that there's myoglobin
in the urine. You can
dip it for myoglobin.
Those dip strips
that you put in the
urine have all
kinds of tests on
them, and one of them
is myoglobin, and
they're pretty
sensitive for that.
The heart also needs
a good blood supply,
so it can not function
to its normal capacity.
You can get liver
failure from diminished
blood flow, and you can
get acute respiratory
distress syndrome.
I talk about that
next year in your ABG,
arterial blood gas
interpretation, and
ARDS lecture. So I'm not
going to talk about it
too much now, but it
is a very severe effect
of many different
types of illnesses.
It's a secondary effect
that the lungs get
filled with this fluid.
And it is not congestive
heart failure, but
it looks like congestive
heart failure on
the x-ray, and it's
treated very differently.
And DIC can occur,
which, as I mentioned,
is very, very
difficult to treat.
Let me just make sure
I didn't lose anything.
Yeah, so labs
to consider. Of
course, you want
to get a glucose.
These people need
sugar because they may
have exerted themselves
and used it up
and use up their
glycogen stores. So you
really want to make
sure that they're
not hypoglycemic. And
that's another reason
to be altered in
your mental status.
so glucose is like
an automatic test
for anyone who has
an altered mental
status it's a very
simple test and
it's very easy to
chew it and it's quite
dramatic when you
give them sugar
you can get a cbc
complete blood count now
when you order tests
as a third year or
even in the icc or
i'm sorry the ferrara
center when you're
doing your sp encounters
and you're writing
your soap notes one of
the rubric missives
to the facilitators is
don't order things
unless they're indicated
and not too expensive
and you have to have
a reason to do it so
anytime you order a
test the only thing
you should ask yourself
before you order it
is how are the results
going to change my
management and when
you really don't know
people as a go-to
answer said well I want
a baseline because I
don't know what's
going to happen later
with my therapy well
in this particular
situation it is a real
need for a baseline because
you don't know where
their blood count
is going to be to
begin with. And if you
rehydrate them and
they're already anemic,
you don't know that
they were not anemic
to begin with. And
they may need to be
transfused. So you do
need a baseline CBC
as well as a baseline
metabolic panel
because you're going
to be repleting many
of these electrolytes.
And so you really
want to know where
you're starting so
you know what your
goals are going to be.
An ABG is often obtained,
an arterial blood
gas, and that'll give
you how much oxygen
is dissolved in the
blood, what the pH is,
and what you're going
to see on your ABG
is you're going to see
a metabolic acidosis
because you're not
perfusing your organs.
Your organs are going
to go into anaerobic
metabolism, and
anaerobic metabolism,
one of the byproducts,
is acid, lactic acid.
So you're going to
have a metabolic
acidosis. And as a
compensatory mechanism for
that metabolic
acidosis, you're going
to breathe faster.
Your respiratory rate
is going to increase
to try to blow off the
carbon dioxide, which
is going to lead
to an alkalosis. So if
you have an acidosis
to start with and
you start to blow off
carbon dioxide by
compensatory respiratory
alkalosis, hopefully
your pH will get
back to more normal
level, closer to 7.4.
but it also accomplishes
another thing
when you breathe
fast, not just
compensating for the
metabolic acidosis.
It also causes you
to dissipate heat.
Remember, we talked
about how you lose
insensate water through
your lungs. Well,
you also dissipate
heat through your
lungs, and that helps
you dissipate more
of it when you're
really hot. You
definitely want to get
a baseline coagulation
profile. If
someone's in DIC, you
need to have a lot
more than just their
INR. An INR is a
way of assessing the
intrinsic and extrinsic
clotting factors,
and you can get what's
called a PT, PTT,
prothrombin time and
a prothromboplastin
time, which
are part of the
INR. But also fibrin
split products,
that will tell
you that you're
potentially in DIC,
and it helps you
guide your therapy
if they do go into
DIC, which is likely
going to happen.
CPK for sure, because
rhabdomyolysis is
definitely common,
and you may want to
potentially even
hydrate them and
dialyze them to get
rid of some of those
breakdown products
of the muscle. That
is a potential
treatment for
rhabdomyolysis. You
want to look at an EKG
because they're
often in dysrhythmia.
And if they have an
altered mental status
and you don't know
for sure that it's
all due to the heat,
well, one of the
reasons is that you
can have meningitis.
So you definitely
want to do a lumbar
puncture and a CT of
the head if you are
not 100% sure that
it's all due to heat.
How do we treat these
people? Well, we cool
them down immediately.
And there are lots
of different methods
to do that. We use
evaporative methods. We
dunk them in cold water
or ice packs. We put
ice packs in the groin
where there's a lot of
blood flow and in the
axilla. We can even
put them in a body bag,
which is kind of
morbid, but it's a very
useful item to fill
with ice and just put
their entire body inside
the body bag, obviously
with a little hole
to breathe through.
And finally, they
may need ECMO, which
is extracorporeal
membrane oxygenation.
So you take all their
blood out of their
body, run it through
a heating machine,
and then, I'm sorry,
a cooling machine,
and then you put it
back in their body. And
people who are getting
heart surgery We
are often put on
cardiopulmonary bypass, and
when you need the
heart to slow down, you
can actually cool it
to make it slow down
so you can operate
on it. So that often
accomplishes the same
kind of goal as ECMO.
Cooling blankets
on the outside, you
can give them water
through an NG tube.
You can irrigate their
bladder with cold
fluid. You can irrigate
their ****** with
cold fluid and their
sigmoid colon. and
even put a catheter
inside the peritoneal
cavity and lavage
them with cool water.
This is the method
that we usually go to
first because it's
cheap and it's easy to
do. We spray them
with water and then we
blow a fan and this
helps evaporate the
fluid and with it
the heat. And this is
very effective, but
one of the side effects
to almost all the
treatment of methods
of cooling people
down is they start to
shiver, which is
counterproductive and going
to raise your body
temperature. So if
people do start to
shiver, then give them
benzodiazepines like
diazepam or lorazepam
to stop them from
shivering because you
don't want them to
make even more heat.
Because it's all wet,
the monitor leads and
you need to watch their
rhythm. So they need
to be on a monitor
are hard to stick on
their body when their
body's all soaking wet.
And you want to use
a really big fan.
This is one of those
fans that they use
to dry the floor
after they polish
it in the hospital.
So just pick it up
and put it on the
table and blow it
across the patient.
It's very effective.
Other cooling methods
are possible, but
they're all poorly
tolerated, and they also
hinder any resuscitative
efforts and may be
impractical. You may
not have all that ice
available to you.
You may not have the
body bag. You may not
have a cold bathtub.
And so if you don't
have it, you can't use
it. But if one fails
for whatever reason
or hinders resuscitative
efforts, then try
another. So you really
should have a lot of
tricks up your sleeve
to cooling people.
Goal is to cool them
down to 37. Don't overdo
it because that can
cause problems too.
You want to give IV
fluids when they're
volume depleted, but the
amount of fluids that
you give to replete
someone's volume are
going to have a little
effect on the cooling
of their body. So not
to cool them down.
It's okay to give IV
fluids that are cooled,
but that's not going to
be the main mechanism
by which you're going
to cool them down.
This is a very important
concept that is
almost on every single
exam that I help write.
When someone is
hot from an ambient
temperature problem or
for an exertional heat
exhaustion or heat
******, Tylenol or
acetaminophen or ibuprofen
or Motrin or Aleve
or any of the non
-steroidals should not
be given. They are
not intended to lower
someone's temperature
when they've been
overwhelmed by ambient
temperature elevation.
Those are intended
to interrupt the
hypothalamic set point
that has been set
inappropriately by an
endogenous pyrogen.
So when you get a bacteria
in your bloodstream
or a virus in your
bloodstream, one
of the reactions that
happens in your body
is that you release
these endogenous
pyrogens, these
chemicals that tell your
hypothalamus to make a
fever. And that is not
the same as your body
being overwhelmed
by being in a hot
environment. So medications
that interrupt these
pyrogen set point
makers like antipyretics,
acetaminophen,
and non-steroidal anti
-inflammatory drugs
are not to be used
in these situations.
Sometimes
people with less
severe heat illness
can go home. Heat
edema, heat stress,
heat cramps, they can
be discharged,
especially if they're
feeling better and
they have nothing else.
But heat ******
patients, they need to
stay. They have
likely going to have
incredible complications
and need to have
multidisciplinary teams
taking care of them
and they need to be
in the ICU full stop.
I hope you enjoyed
this lecture. I
enjoyed giving it
and I'm available
for anyone who
wants to ask me any
questions either by
Zoom or telephone.
I look forward
to communicating
with you. Take care.